hi welcome to cloud on air these are
live webinars the Google's cloud is
hosting and we're doing them every
Tuesday my name is Brian Sullivan I'm
the senior program manager with Google
Earth outreach I'm here with David
kruseman I'm the director of research at
global fishing watch and today we're
gonna be talking about how global
fishing watch uses Google cloud
throughout our whole presentation
there'll be Google or standing by to
answer your questions so you can just
type them in on the platform and they'll
be ready to answer them so let's get
started okay so within Google we have a
team that we call geo for good and our
goal is to take ons on the world's most
pressing issues around the environment
conservation public health and other
humanitarian issues and phishing is
actually one that really relates to a
lot of these issues so when we think of
phishing this is what we traditionally
fish it think of it's a quiet morning
we're out there and we're with nature
but the reality of industrial fishing is
actually quite different and something
that as a society is very difficult to
comprehend this is an example of a
moratorium in China where for three
months they closed fishing so that all
the fish can recuperate and rebound
their stocks but the end of three months
this is what's coming for you and you
can count all the boats that are in here
and once you get a sense of how big you
think this is you can zoom out a little
bit more I get a better extent of just
what global fishing looks like and the
pressures that puts on the environment
and our food you can zoom out one more
time and you can really start to
understand how big this is now we have
these photos because the photojournalist
was out there and they set these up how
could we zoom out and see the entire
world what would that look like we could
truly understand the extent of global
fishing that's what global fishing watch
is enabling us to do so I'm going to
switch over to a live demo now to show
you something that's free for the entire
world and anyone is able to go online
and start to understand how much we're
actually fishing our oceans now the
first thing you'll see is all these blue
dots in the middle and these are our
fishing algorithms that are determining
where we're actually seeing fishing and
this is an interactive map so I can pan
around I can
zoom in to different areas and one of
the things that we'll see is that
there's some spots in the middle of the
Pacific that are wide open and we see
lots of fishing and then we see other
holes in these where we have things like
marine protected areas our country
boundaries that are dictating whether or
not people are allowed to fish in these
regions and you'll see very different
patterns right along the country's
borders versus out in international
water for people are deciding who has
the right to fish there now the same way
we can see this macro view and zoom all
around on this we can actually go in and
see an individual vessel and so what
we'll be doing now is you'll see a pink
line and that is going to be you know an
individual vessel the Valmet al ah the
joys of live demos and - as we play this
forward you'll be able to see an
individual vessel and so out of this
pink line in here we can see how that's
changing let's go into our layers and
we'll go into our our activity and let's
turn off all the other background behind
that and now you can see the distinct
pattern that a boat makes when a fish's
when it's wiggling back and forth like
that versus when it's transiting and it
has those straight lines in between
looking at one more example we can see
where MPAs and other areas like that
have been created
sorry that was problem when you switch
resolutions
all right well thanks for bearing with
us on that but the question is why does
a company like Google look at something
like phishing and so over a billion
people in the world depend on fish as
their primary source of protein about
90% of the apex or the largest species
have disappeared within our lifetime
eighty-five percent of the world's
fisheries are either over fished at
capacity or at recovering about one in
five or 20% of the world's fish are
considered iuu illegal unregulated and
undocumented and then when we look at
this at a global level this is about a
60 billion dollar market that is really
affecting developing countries than most
and that ties down to food security the
town sounds so sovereign rights and a
lot of other issues like slave labor
that you wouldn't think of initially so
let's talk a little bit about how this
is actually working behind the scenes
great thank you Brian
so I'm I'm David Cruz my I run the
research program at global fishing watch
and global fishing watch is a small
nonprofit dedicated increasing
transparency in the global fishing
industry and a lot of what we do is
using Google tools I'm gonna go to
details of how that technology works and
how you make those really nice maps that
Brian just showed us the key technology
is something called automatic
identification system or a is that all
large ocean-going vessels have to carry
and what it does has a little GPS in it
and a broadcast of vessels locations so
the other boats nearby can see where it
is and thus avoid collisions it's a
safety device these signals are
broadcaster radio and they can be picked
up by satellites flying overhead where a
network of antennas along the world's
coast line and we've done a global
fishing launches obtained a global
database of all of these AIS messages
and then process them if you plot all of
these messages on a map what you see is
over one year something that looks like
this is this is one of my favorite maps
you can see all the world's shipping
lanes you can see where fishing is
happening you can see places in New York
tour where boats don't go this is all
vessels only about one out of five of
our fishing boats so now we have this
big database and we have a we have a two
classification problems one we one
identify would
these vessels our fishing vessels and
what type of fishing vessels and - for
those vessels we want to identify when
they're fishing and so this is where we
use the clock we use Google Cloud first
let start with the first problem
identifying what's a fishing vessel in
what type so in a is messages they
broadcast the name and callsign of a
boat and we've been able to take these
messages and match them up to official
registries to figure out what type of
boat about slightly more than fifty
thousand of these almost three hundred
thousand vessels are so that tells us a
whether it's a tugboat whether it's a
trawler and so forth so if this large
training data and then we have to be
able to infer what the other vessels are
fortunately boats have very different
patterns of how they move in the ocean
depending on what type of vessel it is
so here on the left you can see a the
paths of a trawler which is a fishing
vessel that drags a net behind it to
catch fish in the middle is the path of
a longline which as his name applies is
sets long lines of hooks they can be up
to 100 kilometers long in the ocean and
then on the right is a person which in
circles schools of tuna or other fish
with a net and draws them in that way
each of them has a distinct pattern
which you can recognize with your eye
which means we can probably train a
model to do the same thing and
differentiate them but to train that
model first we have to process this data
and create features for our machine
learning algorithm and we do all that in
day and in Google products so every day
we get about 50 million unique s
messages and we run those messages we
paralyze those messages in data flow and
the first thing we do is something very
simple we just create realistic segments
with every all the messages from these
vessels and get rid of noise such that
you have paths that you can work with
there's actually a lot of noise in the
is needs to be cleaned up and then we
put that into bigquery bigquery is
Google's platform
it's an SQL like database that allows
you to do terabytes sized queries this
turns very quickly and it's very useful
for all of our analyses now we have all
these points and we want to figure out
spatial information about each such as
the distance to shore whether it's in
the exclusive economic zone of China or
Japan distance to port and we do that by
taking global shape files such as the
one of all the world's coastlines
one of all the world's ports and do
calculations in data flow to find out
for each for each position in the world
that one kilometer resolution says about
30 million points the distance to the
shore and this is to port would then
take those rasters upload them to
bigquery and then it's very nice we're
able to do a join because that's what
you can do in bigquery across these
millions and millions of positions to
get that spatial information about every
single position so now we have a nice
useful data set in bigquery and we want
to create features for our machine
learning algorithm we have about 30
billion AIS messages and all this is on
the scale of a terabyte and we continue
on data flow to do some calculations for
each single position when you calculate
eleven different features these are
simple things that's just the time
between positions the implied speed
between positions of a vessel how far
that is from shore how far that point is
from from from an anchorage you know the
time of day and so now we have some
information about all those features and
we want to we want to train a model to
identify what type of vote it is based
on these features to do that we use a
common type of machine learning
algorithm called the convolutional
neural network this is a type of this
algorithm has actually become very
common in image recognition is probably
very similar what Google photos use is
to identify what's a cat and what's a
not a cat and and here's here's how it
works
so we're taking you know for each vessel
say we have about thirteen thousand
positions we're gonna try to try to use
identify what type of boat it is and
each of those positions has 11 features
so that's over a hundred thousand
features per vessel and we run something
we're in a convolution a nine layer
convolution across it which essentially
reduces the number of features down to
something more manageable in this case
about two thousand which we can then run
across a fully connected network to get
14 different vessel class probabilities
so the output of this is a number that
tells you whether or not the net neural
net thinks about is a tugboat whether it
thinks is trawler whether it thinks is a
long liner this next slide shows how
well we think something called the
confucian matrix
which is a common tool used for
identifying how well machine'll
algorithms machine learning algorithms
do it classification problems it's a
little complicated to read but basically
the row one row of this is all the
vessels from one class in our test data
and the column is how many of the boats
from that class the neural net thought
was in that class so basically high
numbers along the diagonal is good that
means that vessels from the test data
were labelled with the same value in the
by the neural network and as you look at
this it gets almost it gets the has a
very high accuracy on our to on our on
our data set a lot of the vessels that
gets wrong I've looked at them often
times they're very inactive vessels or
they're some vessels which have kind of
mixed class or outside of these outside
of these fourteen classes so we do a
good job at identifying what's the
fishing boat and what's not and and the
type of fishing vessel so how many boats
are you looking at here we're looking at
so there's there's 300,000 vessels over
all in one year across all yours is
actually closer to 400,000 because some
boats aren't active every year and and
there's about 60,000 fishing vessels
active in one year and 70,000 active
across all yours ok so it's about 70,000
vessels that are being shown in the
public yeah a global fishing watch and
then there's the full 300,000 that we're
doing our own analytics on inside
exactly know that's a good point right
because when you look a little fishing
what you're just seeing the fishing
vessels been owner to identify them we
have to process all the vessels ok so so
that Batmen brings us so now we know oh
the other thing the other thing i think
is really exciting about this is that
big boats move differently than small
boats so our model can also tell how
large the vessels are this is a you know
the length engine power and tonnage of
the x-axis here is from our test data
and the y-axis what the what the model
predicts and does a really good job of
predicting how big boats are which can
be useful for all types of studies so
what you're doing here is you're taking
the ais which is kind of like a gps
track of the boat and the only
information you have is how fast it's
moving and when we're seeing a signal
from that
and with that information you're
figuring out how big of a boat it is how
much power it has and then just like how
much is weighing as well yeah it's it's
kind of I think it's kind of amazing but
it's it's that's exactly what we're
doing so it's like Strava for all the
world's chips exactly actually it's a
yeah they can tell what's a you know and
it's those it's amazing that how much
you can tell just based on how moves
okay so which is its the next thing
which is you want to know what is
fishing so now we know what type of vote
it is and you want to look at how is
moving and you want to say okay this is
a trawler and right now we think it has
its net in the water or this time or you
want to say this is trawl and right now
it doesn't have its it in the water and
it's going to port because you want to
say we're fishing is happening and the
way we do that is we need we just like
with the vessel classification we need
we need label data so we need to know
we're fishing we need to take all the
data label you need to take basically
all the tracts of boats and label each
position as fishing or non fishing okay
this turned out to be a lot of work we
had to manually label more than a
million points this is a case where grad
students are your friend we partnered
with a number of his research
institutions that helped us with this
and we built a a JavaScript tool you can
see a screenshot of it here in something
called PI basa and you can label it we
do is you look at these tracks of the
boat and we were fisheries experts help
train us and you label each position as
fishing or non fishing we labeled more
than a million positions the way we did
this largely also was was me every day i
bothering people on slack and then
sending out encouraging notes or or
critical ones if they were not labeling
enough we did that for two months and
then we were able to train our model so
at Google there's a machine learning
something that's coming up all the time
and usually whenever someone wants to
apply machine learning to a project the
biggest issue is getting training data
and so how long does it take you to
amass a million points like this so it
was we were helped out a lot by the grad
student had basically spent a year doing
this so that was quite helpful
Thank You Kristina if you're listening
and then it took two months to get
another few
hundred basically she did half of it and
then it took us two months to get
another half of that through me
bothering everyone day on slack and end
of team of about ten people spending
each some time there any day so we
calculated that it would take if we do
this across the whole dataset it would
take us about I think it was like four
hundred years to label all the fishing
activity so you're saying if the human
were to do it at the same speed that a
grad student would do it yes that grad
student would be worth as four hundred
years yeah and one of the tricky things
here is we couldn't there's a lot of
nice tools I know Google has been
developing these kind of outsource these
these these labeling projects you know
for creating label data but we actually
had to be trained to do this because
yeah we needed to have kind of expert
decisions about what's fishing versus
not so we couldn't outsource it in the
way we would it might have liked to Oh
so it's a nice example for machine
learning where like if a human looks at
the track they kind of have like an
intuitive sense of why it's fishing or
it's not fishing yeah but there's not
like a clear formula that you can run
the same way and there is just some
extent by gear type and but that's it
all those rules are complicated enough
that it's better to have a human
judgment put on it so and so the output
of it is a table like this this is this
is a view of what's in bigquery and the
far right column is the NS neural net
score and it's one if we think the boat
is fishing and zero or null if we don't
think so now we have every single one of
our data points labeled as fishing or
not fishing and we also think we know
what types of vessels they are so now
what we can do is a now a genome
analyses now we can tell stories and
make maps one thing I do almost every
day is write queries in bigquery and
then also link up to that using using
Python this is a screenshot of an eye
Python notebook where I have a query
that is trying to group the group's data
from a bigquery table into a latitude
and longitude to make a grid I use
pandas library it has a nice as a as a
module for connecting up with bigquery I
take that out into a roster and then I
can map it and do analyses and so here
is a global map of just the fishing
vessels while we think there
in one calendar year and this is a this
is basically a scientific product of the
same thing that Brian showed you earlier
and what we're showing on that global
map we can if I query if I change the
way I write that query to cry only by
specific gear types I can get them out
of we're all trawlers in the world are
and you can see they fish along the
world's coastlines
they often drag their nets along the
seafloor so they stay close to shore
drifting long lines which set those
hooks hundred kilometers long out in the
high seas
per sayings which is circle fish with
their nets and so you can see each
fishing each fishing pattern has a
distinct location in the world so yeah
in summary we are taking in an a speed
from over 30 satellites and hundreds of
terrestrial receivers with almost 50
million AIS messages per day from
300,000 vessels across the year over six
years of data we then also for the
training we're using vessel registries
that in types of boats and also the over
20,000 manually lab labeled track
segments or a million positions we put
that all together through the various
Google tools and what we get out is
about 70,000 fishing vessels 14 gear
types of 14 vessel types of which half
are fishing types the size of vessels
when we think they're fishing and all of
these wonderful maps and data that you
see available one thing I should add is
that we're trying to make as much as
data publicly available as well as our
code base so that our machine where our
machine learning algorithms which we
also run through tensorflow
and cloud ml are our open source and you
can go to global fishing watch do and
find links to those github repos to see
how we actually did this and again it
would take about 400 years from you
bothering you on slack to complete it we
use always lots of did we use Google
products at almost every step of the way
we use data flow which is really nice
for scaling up compute engine instances
so we don't have to worry about
allocating all of our resources or or
keeping too many
running data bigquery is how we store a
lot of our data and run queries on it I
use it every day cloud ml is is an
intensive flow we use for our models
cloud storage as well App Engine is used
on the map as well as Maps API for
showing off the interactive map that
Brian showed you earlier and then I'll
talk a little bit more about Earth
engine which is another platform used
for analysis so one of the things about
global fishing watch is it's a
partnership now between Google that was
a founding partner and initially two
other nonprofit sky truth in Oceana and
now we've stood it up as its own
independent nonprofit so it's been a
great opportunity as these projects were
evolving when we were in the early stage
of the global fishing watch dataflow was
just coming out and so being able to
give external people alpha access to
this to really really refine what were
the features that we needed what worked
well and what didn't
has been really fun and so I know
bigquery is one that we have a whole
team of data scientists I don't really
have the background and systems
administration and really scaling
massive parallel computing but by being
able to do everything directly in
bigquery they were comfortable sequel
and suddenly they were doing these
massive analyses that they wouldn't have
been able to do otherwise and and that's
that's kind of a lot of where I sit
actually because I'm doing a lot of the
analyses and and working with our
engineers who are doing some of the more
distributed stuff has been it's actually
been kind of fun over the last few years
to see us kind of move over to these new
platforms which are auto scaling and
which are kind of doing the same thing
for bigquery the big craze done for me
for some of these like the cloud ml you
know and that and and the computer and
then in the data flow so because at the
end of the day I don't want to worry
about how to scale up all these
computers it's just is all that that's
why bigquery so nice because I never
have to think about the parallelization
it just does it so the Mac brings us
back to the analysis I'm saying really
what we care about is getting useful
information out of this and so the large
part of my job is working with eleven
different research institutions in our
research program to take this massive
data set and turn it into useful
knowledge and we're doing that through
over twenty five different research
projects we have ten papers already
published many
more in the works and maybe two examples
of what we can do with this one is just
simply people are trying to understand
how phishing responds to different
temperatures so we're looking at here is
animation the background shows sea
surface temperature and then the dark
blue is is drifting longline fishing
activity over the course of one year and
you can watch how you can watch the
fishing activity move and you watch the
temperatures change some of the
researchers are building models to see
how fishing responds to changing
temperatures you know just to make sure
we understand you're saying that the
near the equator the waters a lot hotter
yeah so you can actually see like little
jet streams and things like this coming
off of I may not be the right scientific
term right you can see currents coming
through here and how those temperatures
are shifting and all the wheeling dots
in the middle is we're using longline
and then down here this would be much
colder water near the poles yeah
and now I'm gonna zoom in now to between
Australia and Africa the colors will
change yellow is very warm black is cold
and the white is fishing activity and
this is between May and September of
2016 and you can watch and see the
fishing activity follow this kind of
constant temperature as that as the
gradient moves northward and it's really
cool and and we've been able to at how
this changes between years and we can
now model this and this is useful for
all types of things ranging from how we
manage the oceans now and thinking about
where fishing is happening how out
allocate permits to think about how to
respond to climate change and we built
this this this graphic you're seeing
here was built using Earth engine which
is a Google platform for doing very
large global raster calculations and
that's what the their sea surface
temperature model built into it at very
high resolution daily that we're able to
compare with our fishing activity so
we're seeing as the waters get warmer
and moved north you're saying the fish
fall that same temperature yeah and then
the fishing boats or the Predators are
following that the same way and I think
there's actually researchers that are
looking at like what would be the
migration paths for different fish and
other species like that as we have sea
surface temperatures rising across the
board and then how all the ones be
squeezed in and out and so this is
giving new tools for them to look at
that weren't really possible or
available before a second project that's
good to highlight is something called
transshipment so some vessels instead of
returning to port and offloading the
fish at port they meet up with
refrigerated cargo vessels at seed
offload their fish and this is a you
know they do this partially because
sometimes it can save fuel but another
reason is that it can also help obscure
where the fish was caught and what
vessel caught the fish and this is one
way that a legally caught fish enters
legitimate markets it also allows
vessels to stay at sea for a very long
time without coming to the port which
has been implicit which has been shown
to be associated with instances of
essentially slavery at sea and also
other illicit activities and so our
essential goal is to create transparency
you know not all this trend shipment is
bad but where our goal is to create
transparency we can understand where
it's happening and so we can better
assess its activity if you could imagine
this is a basically we have all the
businesses of all the boats in AIS and
we want to see when two boats meet up at
sea which is basically a cross join
between tens of millions in positions
which is an enormous calculation we do
this in data flow by gritting the world
up and and breaking it down into smaller
pieces so we can identify every where
one fishing vessel meets up with a
refrigerated cargo vessel at sea for
several hours and from that we're able
to create the first-ever global map of
transshipment behavior so this shows
that the red dots here show everywhere
we see refrigerated cargo vessel and a
and a fishing vessel meet up at sea and
the light blue dots are places where we
see where we think transhipment might be
occurring with less confidence so what
you're saying is like if you look in
these photos this smaller boat is the
actual fishing vessel and then that
pulls alongside the larger refrigerated
vessel or like a tanker yeah and then
they offload everything from the small
boat onto the big boat and so the big
boat may not actually be fishing but it
meets up with all these small boats
around the area and then brings that
back into central yeah and I mean and
the reason you want to do this is
because big boats are more efficient at
crossing the ocean than small boats
since you can see fuel if you do this
but again it also
skiers supply chains okay so and so
Brian's gonna talk a little more about
why this matters so one of the other
impacts that we've seen of chance
shipments is that the same way they'll
be moving fish from a fishing vessel on
to a cargo vessel they also bring
supplies and all kinds of other
materials back onto the fishing vessel
so the fishing vessel could stay out for
months and months at a time and the AP
did some incredible investigative
reporting and what they found is that in
a lot of these cases the crew is
actually related to slave labor because
they're literally trapped on the boat
and unable to leave and so being able to
help map out where trench shipments were
happening was a key piece for helping
them to understand where these vessels
might be going and how these supplies
are going and in those pictures you saw
earlier of this shipment vessels those
are actually taking from satellites the
working with members of global fishing
watch who are you looking at a is data
of those larger cargo vessels and saying
we think there's a boat here why don't
you tell your satellite to take a
picture so it's it's yeah and that's
moved on to I think the next slide is
here's another example where in Palau
people are looking at poaching that was
happening within a small country in the
Asia Pacific and in many cases being
able to see this as it was happening
they were able to send out enforcement
vehicles from the government to pull
alongside these and the New York Times
magazine did a whole piece on the story
of how a lot of these developing
countries are being taken advantage of
by more developed and industrial fishing
countries and companies to exploit this
and so adding transparency to a space
that was traditionally out of sight and
out of mind is really revolutionising
the way people can more sustain manage
these areas Indonesia is a country that
we've been working closely with the
person here in this picture is EBU Suzie
she's the Minister of Fisheries and
foreign affairs she reports directly to
President jokowi and surely after we
first announced that were working on
global fishing watch she came to Google
and she met with us and she said how do
I use technology like this in Indonesia
and so she's been extreme
we progressive and she's the first
country ever to take what was
traditionally very proprietary data
so she's supplementing our AIS work with
what we call VMs or vessel monitoring
systems which is proprietary government
data and what they found is that while a
lot of these countries and companies
have more de than they can handle the
challenge isn't the lack of data the
challenge is pulling out insights from
that and so by taking her data and
running it through all of our machine
learning programs we've been able to
give her back a lot of the other
insights and let her and her teams and
her Navy have more views into what's
actually happening so they can focus on
specific things said swimming in all
that data when we talked about
transshipment it really does enable a
scale of fishing that was never possible
before and so this is a very sobering
picture in the hull of a boat in the
Galapagos and you were literally looking
at thousands and thousands of sharks
that had been thinned and cut and what
ended up happening as we zoom out as you
can see how they've been removed in
different areas use our hammerhead
sharks and silky sharks there's some
tuna in there as well and so working
with National Geographic and as well as
many of the Galapagos conservative
groups they were able to go in and they
said that these are thousands if not
tens of thousands of sharks this is
historic this is the biggest seizure of
sharks in the history of Galapagos for
sure and what happened in the end is the
the boat that they caught was fined
about six million dollars and the crew
is currently in jail and the Ecuadorian
Av did an incredible job of bringing
that in and then trying them in their
court systems but what they tried them
for is somewhat of a loophole because
they were transporting endangered
species through a marine protected area
but what global fishing watch isn't
allowing people to do is start to
understand that network of other vessels
that were involved in that and
transshipped their catch onto this boat
because this boat itself wasn't the one
that was doing all of that fishing so so
I think that I think that's a really
good point the fishing was actually
happening elsewhere in the ocean and
really what
what's exciting about this is that the
heist is the ocean is kind of this last
frontier in this this area that's the
synonymous with like things that you
can't tell us happening there right and
so what happens is that we over fish and
all those things are caught and all
these these dangerous species are being
caught and and it's a huge management
problem and once you can see what's
actually happening there people can
start to take action to make and do
something and so I think that's it it's
a place where I think it's really dated
like new data is really exciting because
it makes a difference this is another
example this is the Sanchi this was a
oil tanker that crashed with another
vessel out in the middle of the Asia
Pacific and because I had so much oil
and other toxic areas on it it ignited
and it burned for well over a week in
the middle of the high seas and so this
was an oil spill that's on par with a
lot of the other famous ones that people
have heard about in the US but because
it's happening out in the middle of the
ocean it's not really getting any
coverage the same way and it's really
really difficult to estimate what the
impact this will have as toxins are
leaking out all over and because we've
made all of our data completely open
reuters gone on and they started
modeling what the effects of that tanker
are going to be and so they built out an
area that looked at where the oil was
going to spread and then they brought in
all the global fishing watch data as
well and we're able to say over that
same 2 or 3 week period that they were
able to actually I think is about a
three month period that they modeled out
where the oil was able to go they could
see which fishing grounds were going to
be affected and as we look at other ways
of integrating global fishing watch data
there's a huge opportunity to work with
local markets so that you could actually
see where your fish was caught and
whether it may or may not have been in
the vicinity of some of these natural
disasters or man-made disasters as
they're happening there's another
example here that's I think very telling
traditionally when new marine protected
areas wanted to be created there's often
pushback from local industry and other
areas and what's happening here is there
is a new marine protected area they're
trying to create in Mexico
and that's this little red box in here
that they tried to do and I'll try to do
this live we'll see if it cooperates
this time
one more time and so when they went in
the industry had said look if you close
this area to fishing we'll lose job
security we'll lose the fish that we
need to feed the country and everything
else and traditionally this is always
been very one-sided because industries
have this information but governments
and NGOs and other public interest
groups have not had access to this with
global fishing watch they are able to
say ok here is everywhere
that Mexican fishing vessels are fishing
and what we're able to see is that that
little red area there is less than 4% of
the total fish and the total profits
that are being collected by this and a
lot of the work is being done out and
the high sees it and it's it's really
great because these arguments usually
they can start having conversations
about actual numbers and things once you
bring this to the table because before
it's like people come to the table with
like no marine protected areas are gonna
destroy our business and or marine
protected areas are great and they're
gonna save the ocean now we can actually
actually we're going to save they're
gonna prevent this percentage of fishing
and save this much area and then that
allows you to actually make progress and
have real conversations in that case
National Geographic and pristine seas
has a program where they work with local
governments to enable them to have
access to this other type of information
and figure out from a scientific
perspective where these policies can be
done and in the last year or two they've
actually created new 5 marine protected
areas using data from global fishing
watch some of these areas are you know
larger than California twice the size of
Germany and we're seeing this all over
the world now and are really excited
about it so one of the things that's
exciting about this is that global
fishing watch would not have been
possible five years ago
satellite data didn't have the global
coverage that we need there from a
regulatory perspective a lot of these
vessels did not use to publicly
broadcast and we're seeing more and more
pressure from that but then finally the
computing power was never there to
handle massive massive amounts of this
data and be able to scale it over an
area that you didn't have to be a
hardcore computer programmer to start to
be able to tease out that information
and be able to visualize
everything in a simple webpage that's
free and public and anybody in the world
can go in and see that and so we're
really excited by the fact that you know
five years ago this wasn't possible it's
just starting to be possible now and it
keeps growing and growing and a lot of
things that you've seen we've done all
just off of kind of the equivalent of a
GPS broadcast but now the next wave is
going to be looking at all kinds of
satellite imagery and radar and other
ones to get an even bigger sense of what
extent were fishing our oceans so we can
better manage them for the future so
thanks very much and I think we have
questions coming shortly
you
all right well welcome back all right so
we have some questions from the audience
some of these are often the questions we
we frequently get asked and there's a
couple new ones in here too so all right
the first question is why can't boats
just turn off their a s and you'll never
see them they can't that's the answer
but the trick is you can see when they
turn it off it's away from shore and so
you can and that's suspicious and so we
can highlight it and we've done some
analyses where we compare the number of
days at sea for certain fleets with
official statistics and it does quite
well so this is a problem in some
specific parts of the world do we have
to do more investigation on but for most
the data said that is not a huge problem
okay and actually I think Oceana another
nonprofit that we've worked with has
recently released a report where they
have looked at across the globe and they
said show me examples of boats that have
kind of consistently been turning it off
they're a is just as they're approaching
protected areas or other exclusive
economic zones and we're not saying
what's legal or what sea legal but we're
putting the data out there to start
having conversations and we think that's
really the value of transportation and
to be clear there are places where this
is an issue that requires that type of
attention that Oceana has brought to it
okay so do you see any difference
between running the machine learning
models and virtual machines versus in
cloud ml and did you get any uplift and
have you played with GPUs or cheap use
yeah it's really quite ml is really nice
because the auto scaling so you don't
need to officially you don't have to
allocate all of your machines beforehand
is allow us to do things much more
efficiently we have not been able to use
TP use tensor processing units but we
have moved to GPUs which have about 10
to 20 times more efficient faster than
then doing our our model on CPUs which
is really nice makes a big difference
and I think what's happened is not only
is it so much faster but then it also
decreases your costs because you're not
running the machines for as long as you
need all right so it sounds like you're
basing this whole project off of a is
other types of tracking information you
can use so I think we actually touched
on that a little bit in there so
governments like Indonesia are coming
forward and providing their own
that's a monitoring system data and so I
was actually in June of last year at the
UN oceans event we stood up with EBU
Susi and we launched all the indonesian
data in there as well and since then
we've actually built out a team of about
three or four people that are in
indonesia working with the local
government to to provide them access to
these tools and build the type of custom
reports and tools that they need to push
these further and we also talked a
little bit about how we're just starting
to use a lot more satellite imagery and
radar in other areas to measure what we
call the dark fleet our vessels that
aren't broadcasting and and we're
actually soon you're gonna be adding to
go fishing watch a layer where you can
there's another thing called up beers
which is a satellite from NOAA that
looks at night lights and so squid
fishing vessels fish with really bite
lights and so these satellites can
actually see those and we were starting
to match those up to fishing vessels and
we'll be able to see you'll be to see
that soon in global fishing watch that
layer of that satellite so you'll be
able to see those night lights and it's
really interesting with some places
where there's boats that don't have a is
but our fishing a squid and you can see
that now in this map how can people get
access to the data global fishing watch
org and global fishing watch dot io that
works just google it yeah it's a we over
east so the the raw AIS tracks we can't
release all of those because some of
those are proprietary but we have we
have a high resolution grated fishing
effort by vessel and that you can buy
day so you can really kind of dig down
to the results of this this is models
and I think you've made it available and
CSVs
when bigquery directly so you can play
with it it's also been rasterized and
available in Earth engine so if you want
to bring it in along with sea surface
temperature or depth in other areas like
that it's all in one package already and
on global fishing watch that I oh
there's sample code and blog posts
describe each of those so bigquery and
Earth engine how to access them okay as
much I highly recommend using those over
the CSV is because the CSV is just give
you a 25 gigabyte file and it's much
harder to deal with okay and then
finally in the last 30 seconds what's
wrong where are the holes with where do
you lack coverage Oh Nora it's perfect
so the main issue is the not all boats
have a is and it varies by region we
have a you can we've dove into this on a
recent science publication you can look
in the more supplement materials there's
a pairs a large table saying by country
but we have documented this quite
extensively there's also some regions
where I asked coverage not quite as good
but by and large it's a problem that's
we can address great all right well
thanks so much pleasure today and I
think there's another one coming next